So I'm going to turn this over to Sunghwan Kim
and he is going to take you through teaching PubChem
Hello everyone thank you very much for joining
us today.
For the next 20 minutes or so I will talk
about how to use PubChem in the chemistry
classroom.
So what is PubChem?
PubChem is a public chemical information resource
at NIH.
Basically what it does is collect chemical
information from hundreds of data sources
in the public domain and disseminated back
to the public free of charge.
PubChem is a very popular chemistry website.
For example, last March we had more than 2.9
million unique users.
Then who are our users?
Generally speaking, about a half of our users
are between age 18 and 24.
And those in this age group are likely to
be college students.
Many of them are required to take some chemistry
courses like general chemistry, organic chemistry.
Then you may wonder how they use PubChem?
The most common use case of PubChem is a search
through Google.
If you use Google to search for chemical by
name, usually it gives a PubChem record at
the top of the search result.
Then click it to go to PubChem and get the
information.
Basically, students are using PubChem as a
reference material like CRC handbook or Merck
index.
Essentially, this has been a traditional activity
in the chemistry classroom for decades, or
perhaps centuries.
Let's suppose that you want to find some property
of a chemical.
Let's say the boiling point of ethanol.
You can find it from PubChem much quicker
than from any hardcopy references . But at
the end of the day, what you learn from this
activity is still the boiling point of ethanol,
regardless of where you find it.
And the educational value of this activity
is not very different, regardless of what
reference you views.
What additional educational values can PubChem
provide compared to the 19th century Merck
index?
To answer this question, we have to look at
PubChem in a different way.
Most people view PubChem as a single information
resource.
But you can also view PubChem as a gateway
to many information resources.
In other words, PubChem provides access to
all sorts of chemical information scheduled
across hundreds of data sources.
With that said, the students are now exposed
to an extremely large amount of data.
So it is necessary for us to help them to
get the most out of this big chemical information.
It means more emphasis of chemical education
should be given to chemical education.
What can you teach using PubChem ? Here are
some examples.
And we are going to review them briefly during
this webinar.
First, PubChem can be used to help students
to build the ability to critically assess
chemical data.
Today I will show you two examples.
The first one is about finding the boiling
point of benzene from PubChem.
This is a screenshot for the PubChem compound
summary page for benzene.
The compound summary page provides an aggregated
view of all information available in PubChem
for a given compound.
If you scroll down this page, you will find
the boiling point section for benzene.
Currently PubChem has six boiling point data
from five different sources.
Some sources used Fahrenheit and others used
Celsius with various precisions.
And once source explicitly specify the atmosphere
pressure at which the boiling point was measured.
Which is a good practice.
And importantly, some gave a single value
as a boiling point while others gave a range
of values.
Actually, one source gave two boiling points.
One as a value and the other as a range of
values.
What is going on?
If you click these source names, the hidden
part it is a expanded and now you can see
one is for benzene and the other is for coal
tar.
And you can see that the links to the webpage
where the data was collected from.
So what is happening here is that 176 is the
boiling point of benzene.
But the other is for coal tar.
Coal tar is a mixture of various hydrocarbons
including benzene.
So you can get benzene from coal tar through
distillation.
Basically, coal tar is the natural source
of benzene.
So, some sources used benzene and coal tar
interchangeably.
And that is also reflected in PubChem through
data integration.
So from this example, the students can learn
that there are multiple contexts of a chemical.
And understand why they are integrated in
a single record.
And realize that care should be taken when
searching for chemical data.
The next example is about finding CAS numbers
for SIO two from PubChem.
In PubChem SIO two has 22 CAS numbers.
Each of these CAS numbers represent a different
context of SIO two.
Depending on whether it means SIO 2 in general
or a specific form.
Or solid SIO 2, can be amorphous or crystalline.
The crystalline SIO 2 can be classified into
different polymorphs.
And the property of SIO 2 depends on how it
is processed and whether it is pure or it
contains some contaminants.
In PubChem, all of these are aggregated into
a single record because they have the same
chemical formula.
SIO 2.
So again, from this example, students can
learn the importance of the context of chemical
data.
Now the second one is about how to search
PubChem by chemical structure.
You can type a chemical name into the Google
search box but what would you do if you don't
know the name of the compound but it's a structure?
In PubChem, you have two options.
First, you can draw the structure using molecular
drawing software called PubChem sketcher,
or use a line notation for the structure.
Several line notations for chemical structures
have been developed but the most commonly
used ones are SMILES, InChI, and InChiKey
and all of these are supported in PubChem.
Currently, PubChem has two structure search
interfaces.
Chemical structure search is older but the
stable interface.
And PubChem search beta uses newer technologies
but it was released as a test version.
You can access the two structures search interfaces
from the PubChem homepage.
And both interfaces support various types
of search including identity search, substructure,
superstructure search, similarity search,
and molecular formulas search.
And you can provide the infrastructure using
PubChem compound ID, or line notations like
smiles, InChI, and InChiKey.
You can also draw the infrastructure using
the PubChem sketcher or upload a file that
contains the inpu structure.
And PubChem is actively working on a new interface
that will replace the two existing interfaces.
So please stay tuned.
Another important topic to cover is structure
clustering and structure activity analysis.
Or SAR analysis.
Structure clustering is about grouping compounds
into small clusters according to their structural
similarities.
It is helpful in classifying molecules is
according to their structural characteristics.
As an example, these are some anti-allergic
agents from PubChem.
They can be grouped into three major clusters.
Like dipeptides, glucocorticoids, and antihistamines.
Based on these clustering results, you can
expect that the anti-allergic activities of
these compounds may come from three different
mechanisms of action.
And SAR analysis is about clustering compounds
and bioassay data simultaneously.
It is useful for identifying structural characteristics
responsible for the bio activity of molecules.
Unfortunately the structure clustering and
SAR analysis tools will be retired by the
end of this year but the same tasks can be
done using third-party software after downloading
necessary data from PubChem.
The last one is automated data retrieval using
a computer code.
PubChem provides multiple programmatic aspects
routes.
Among them PUG-REST is the simplest and easiest
to learn.
It can be used with popular programming languages
like Python, so students can learn to automate
data retrieval from PubChem by writing a short
script.
Let me briefly talk about Cheminformatics
OLCC.
It was an NSF funded project led by Professor
Belford at the University of Arkansas, Little
Rock.
And PubChem was actively involved in this
project as part of our outreach effort for
the chemical education community.
Teaching chemical cam informatics to undergraduate
chemistry majors has many unique challenges.
First cheminformatics is not a field of chemistry
but a mix of many different fields.
Because of that not so many faculty members
have the expertise to keep teach the course.
In addition to that, there is no textbook
suitable for undergraduate chemistry majors.
There are some cheminformatics textbooks.
But most of them are written for computer
science majors or graduate students.
Or cover narrow topics that focuses on medicinal
chemistry and drug discovery.
Cheminformatics OLCC aimed to address these
issues, at least partially.
In Cheminformatics OLCC, experts were recruited
from various places including industry, government
and academia.
And they prepared reading materials and homework
problems sets.
And they were made available online through
the OLCC website.
And the instructors at multiple participating
schools used these online materials to deliver
the Cheminformatics course at their schools.
Concurrently the instructors had face to face
meetings with the students in the classroom
at the same time the Cheminformatics experts
got engaged in online discussions with students
through OLCC website.
We ran this course twice.
In fall, 2015.
We had about 30 students from four schools.
And in spring, 2017, there were about 50 students
from 10 schools.
All the course materials developed during
this course are available at the OLCC website,
olcc.ccce.divched.org, and Libre Texts, chem.libretexts.org.
So if anybody wants to use these materials
for his own course, he can use them for free.
And many of the course materials covered PubChem
data, tools, and services.
Here, is a quick summary of PubChem related
topics covered in the Cheminformatics OLCC.
Basically it includes everything I mentioned
today and more.
In summary, a majority of PubChem users are
likely to be college students.
And they use PubChem as a reference material.
But, there are many other things that students
can do beyond this use case.
PubChem can also be used as a free online
Cheminformatics education resource.
And Cheminformatics OLCC is a good example.
And finally, we are very interested in working
together with the chemical education community.
So if you're interested, please reach out
to us for collaboration.
Thank you and I am more than happy to answer
your questions.
[Peter Cooper] Thank you Sunghwan.
We will leave it open for a couple of minutes
to see if there are any questions.
We do have a couple of questions.
Let me get to those.
So there are two questions that relate to
the same thing.
One, what third-party tools can be used to
replicate the SAR functions that will be discontinued?
[Sunghwan] We are not allowed to endorse any
commercial software or third-party software
so we cannot answer that question.
But if you send me an email, I can tell you
about that.
In person.
[Peter] I think it is okay if you want to.
To mention something.
We don't endorse it.
An example would be fine.
[Sunghwan] In my opinion, R is the best one,
it is free.
It runs on PC and Mac and Linux.
And in the case of R there are many tutorials
out there.
So you can start from there.
[Peter] Thank you.
I don't see any additional questions right
now.
So thanks everybody for coming.
And we are having another webinar next week
on BLAST.
Please check that out.
Thank you very much for coming.